[Música]
escala en París Braulio Moro
Bienvenidos a una nueva emisión de
escala en París un programa que cada
semana da la palabra a representantes de
la política las ciencias la cultura y
claro está de la sociedad civil un
programa de radio Francia internacional
con las veinticuatro en español las
relaciones entre Francia y los países de
América Latina y el Caribe tienen una
prolongada y rica historia el
aprendizaje de esas relaciones pasa
entre otras vías por la formación
académica Una institución creada hace ya
68 años se ocupa de la enseñanza
superior sobre esas relaciones el
instituto de altos estudios para América
Latina y el Caribe y heal por sus siglas
en francés hoy recibimos aquí en esta
escala en París a Denisse merkellen
director del Instituto de altos estudios
para América Latina Denise Bienvenido a
esta escala en París Muchísimas gracias
Es un gusto un placer tenerle con
nosotros es usted el segundo director
del Instituto de altos estudios de
América Latina y el Caribe de origen
latinoamericano que ocupa ese puesto
después de Jackson cómo ve usted los
desafíos que hoy la educación superior
del instituto que usted encabeza
bueno tenemos una como usted dice una
vieja y
rica tradición de recepción de
estudiantes latinoamericanos el
Instituto recibe aproximadamente 30% de
su estudiantado proveniente de distintos
países de América Latina y hay una
cooperación muy rica y muy fluida con
universidades de todos los países del
del subcontinente e incluso de Estados
Unidos con los colegas que que trabajan
sobre sobre América Latina Entonces
tenemos también una cantidad importante
de
profesores e investigadores invitados
tenemos cátedras las cátedras Simón
Bolívar la cátedra Pablo Neruda etcétera
distintas cátedras que nos permiten
recibir a colegas del mundo entero
especializados en América Latina y el
interés por América Latina en Francia
entre el público Franco parlante se ha
renovado muchísimo estos años se ha
enriquecido con nuevas investigadores
Entonces estamos muy contentos y
funcionamos muy bien Tenemos también una
cooperación importante con otras
universidades europeas que trabajan
sobre América Latina
este entonces Bueno ahí hay muy muy rico
interés y muy fluido intercambio Y eso
nos nos hace la tarea muy agradable y al
mismo tiempo Claro está en 68 años la
situación ha cambiado particularmente de
un tiempo para acá a nivel de la
educación superior ustedes se enfrentan
me imagino problemas como es la libertad
de expresión la verdadera libertad de
cátedra El problema del huquismo el
problema de los señalamientos que se
producen en algunas universidades viven
ustedes esto al interior del instituto o
no no lo vivimos puertas adentro porque
trabajamos en un clima de pluralismo que
protegemos y que
preservamos como nuestro más preciado
bien la libertad de cátedra Es
verdaderamente un valor muy importante
para nosotros sobre todo que tenemos una
vinculación con la vida política de las
sociedades latinoamericanas y de la
sociedad francesa también entonces
realmente trabajamos en una situación de
mucha comodidad con colegas de muchos
puntos de vista y esa esa riqueza de de
puntos de vista es fundamental para
nosotros se expresa porque tenemos
muchas disciplinas Antropología historia
economía sociología ciencia política
geografía dentro del instituto y también
porque tenemos puntos de
académico científicos y políticos que
conviven dentro del instituto no la
relación de las ciencias sociales con la
vida social no puede ser de una
separación estricta no entonces ahí hay
un juego complejo muchas ante arcoíris
precisamente de especializaciones sí a
veces la vida política se nos mete
y penetra la vida de la Universidad de
una manera en que no lo quisiésemos es
muy tentador para para el poder de
turnos a este democrático no
inmiscuirse en los asuntos de la
universidad y nosotros tenemos que
mantener un diálogo pero no podemos
permitir que la vida política ni en
proveniencia de los movimientos sociales
ni del poder político
dicte las orientaciones de la
investigación y de la docencia no
ciertamente y al mismo tiempo es usted
un observador como sociólogo además
director del Instituto de altos estudios
un observador de la realidad
latinoamericana me gustaría comentar con
usted se han producido una serie de
procesos electorales estos últimos
tiempos en América Latina lo que se
llamó la segunda ola del llamado
progresismo por no decir de la izquierda
latinoamericana pero parece que
rápidamente Está girando hacia una
especie de decepción los resultados
recientes sobre la Constituyente en
Chile la crisis que atraviesa Argentina
las propuestas no resueltas de la
presidenta de Honduras dando a entender
que como que hay una especie de
decepción desesperanza que se había
recreado en una parte de América Latina
sí que tiene numerosos componentes y
componentes diferentes según los países
en Argentina por ejemplo la crisis
económica de la mano de la inflación
galopante que corroe
a estas alturas porque 100% de inflación
corroe Los lazos sociales y los vínculos
sociales del conjunto de la sociedad
hacen muy difícil la situación no es
esta situación igual en los otros países
no chile no atraviesa por una situación
similar por ejemplo sin embargo
pareciera haber un denominador común que
es la profunda división de las
sociedades latinoamericanas Por una
parte lo vemos en Argentina lo vemos en
Chile lo vemos en Brasil lo vivimos en
Bolivia anteriormente
se ve en muchos lugares no las
sociedades latinoamericanas están
profundamente divididas Y eso conlleva
una o tiene como mar de fondo
probablemente una crisis de los
regímenes democráticos que
se ven desde el punto de vista de
Como cada vez más impotentes para
resolver los problemas acuciantes que se
presentan a las distintas sociedades no
crisis que además se refleja también en
la reemergencia en la reaparición de una
tendencia dijéramos al autoritarismo por
no decir de las dictaduras en América
Central notablemente el caso de
Nicaragua por no citar sin uno pero
también El Salvador Guatemala lo que
está pasando hoy en día en Ecuador este
resurgimiento de gobiernos autoritarios
hace reflejo o reflejaría de alguna
manera precisamente esta crisis de la
Democracia latinoamericana sin duda y No
es simplemente el progreso de corrientes
políticas autoritarias hay un movimiento
profundo en las sociedades que le están
diciendo a los gobiernos y a los Estados
no es lo mismo el gobierno y el estado
pero le dicen a sus gobernantes Hay algo
en el funcionamiento del estado que no
puede seguir así
hay una crisis de los estados nacionales
y en consecuencia una crisis de los
regímenes democráticos las los regímenes
democráticos no pueden
sobrevivir a tales niveles de fractura
social a tales niveles de fractura
política los regímenes democráticos
necesitan de niveles de cohesión social
de los cuales las sociedades
latinoamericanas se han alejado y por
más que tengamos elecciones incluso
diría Por más que tengamos elecciones y
Libertad de prensa no lograremos tener
regímenes democráticos sanos en el
Continente tanto como las sociedades
estén profundamente divididas no esto ha
tenido algunas expresiones muy claras el
poder judicial del que el del que
difícilmente hablamos o con dificultad
se habla sino para decir que está
manipulado que es corrupto etcétera ha
perdido su lugar
ha visto está desestabilizado en el
equilibrio de poderes del funcionamiento
de un democrático ese es otro síntoma de
lo que ocurre es muy difícil para los
gobiernos construir o reconstruir o
repensar en el contexto actual un
equilibrio de poderes en el seno del
Estado 68 años del instituto cuentan
mucho evidentemente Yo quisiera
preguntarle Denisse merecen en diciembre
pasado usted escribió una editorial
respecto a una situación que se presentó
cuando el Instituto el caso de
un extorsionador de un torturador
argentino Mario Sandoval quien fue
profesor del instituto de altos estudios
entre si no mal recuerdo 1999 y el 2005
este personaje ha sido condenado por la
justicia Argentina él fue profesor del
instituto fue condenado por secuestro
tortura y desaparición forzada de un
estudiante de una universidad en
Argentina usted publicó una editorial
bastante Clara sobre ese tema ya como
presidente del instituto no obstante
esto se produjo en una situación donde
queda poco claro
qué hicieron las autoridades en su
momento del instituto de altos estudios
de América Latina para evitar que este
individuo entrase al instituto Cómo cómo
aprecia usted el que no haya habido
sanción el que no haya ninguna situación
de reconocimiento de lo que hizo el
Instituto en ese momento
bueno las en primer lugar aclarar Mario
Sandoval la persona de la que estamos
hablando que fue condenada efectivamente
por crímenes de lesa humanidad en
Argentina en tribunal en Argentina en
diciembre pasado
fue ya sé de q es el
encargado de cursos es el título Exacto
es decir él no tenía Rango de profesor
son esos puestos que se utilizan para
atraer gente a la universidad que viene
por ejemplo un periodista a hablar de la
prensa o un realizador de cine hablar de
cine en fin gente que por su experiencia
profesional se acerca a una universidad
o jóvenes docentes que están iniciando
la carrera nunca fue titular
de la sorbona ni del instituto de alto
estudios de América Latina cosa que él
sí se encargó de reivindicar y de y de y
de presentar en en muchos lugares de
América Latina no
nosotros no estábamos en el instituto en
aquel entonces las autoridades de la
época se refugian diciendo que no sabían
Quién era Mario Sandoval se presentó con
un currículum donde decía claramente que
él había sido oficial de la Policía
Federal Argentina durante la dictadura
militar en un instituto especializado en
ese momento entre otras cosas en la
enseñanza de la justicia transicional de
las dictaduras que habían asolado el
continente en los años 70 hay ahí una
parte de misterio no ha habido proceso
judicial Al respecto porque no hay una
falta legal cometida
creo que es una pregunta que que debe
hacerse a los responsables de la época
no para nosotros
latinoamericanos para quienes vivimos La
dictadura las algunas de las dictaduras
en en América Latina es mi caso por por
la Argentina y por el Uruguay tuve la
mala suerte de vivir ambas
es un poco o doloroso y un poco
misterioso pensar que un personaje de
semejante Calibre del cual se comienza a
saber también una actuación francesa
como como sus no se trata simplemente de
un argentino miembro de la dictadura que
ocultó su pasado y vivió normalmente en
Francia comenzamos a saber que por las
investigaciones periodísticas que ha
habido también probablemente o con toda
seguridad una actuación no Clara sino
más bien turbia en el seno del Estado
francés entonces lo que nosotros pedimos
a la justicia en aquel entonces fue que
la extradición fuese posible para que la
justicia Argentina pudiese llevar
adelante sus investigaciones
afortunadamente ocurrió
bueno corresponde ahora Investigar qué
es lo que ocurrió en Francia durante
todos esos años Pues con esta aclaración
Que queda hecha llegamos al final de
esta escala en París no me queda sino
agradecerle a Denisse merlen director
del Instituto de altos estudios para
América Latina y el Caribe El ihear su
presencia en esta escala en París
Muchísimas gracias Muchísimas gracias
acompañado a ustedes les damos una nueva
cita aquí la próxima semana en otra
escala en París
[Música]